out of quarantine the who experts can
finally begin
their investigation on the ground the
question now is
are they going to be taken for a ride
will you be visiting the wuhan institute
of virology
effectively i was shouting questions at
a bus the chinese authorities
as ever are keeping journalists at a
distance
but this will need to be more than a
coach tour investigation if it's to
appease critics
both of china and the whole
every activity must conform to the
investigation into scientifically
tracing the origins of the coronavirus
the highest priorities of which are to
prevent future risks
and safeguard the safety and health of
people's lives
in regards to the team of experts detail
work schedule
i suggest you reach out to the relevant
department for further information
the who team can now visit sites in
wuhan
the original epicenter of covert 19 more
than a year ago
they include the juanan market where the
first ever cluster was centered
long ago it was disinfected and boarded
up
but this was the unsanitized reality
this is zhang hai's father who died in
the early days of the pandemic
his son blames the chinese government
for his father's death
and wants to meet the who experts
china is happy to examine the past so
long as it's the glorious version
this is an exhibition center currently
open in wuhan
detailing the triumphs of the fight
against kovid
here the timeline begins only in january
2020.
not before the period the who are
interested in when covert cases were
mounting
and authorities were silencing
whistleblowers
a pandemic take on madame two swords and
how true to life
is up for debate you can see the care
that has gone into the exhibits here and
is an
absolutely sprawling space to show what
china considers the official
narrative and that's where the tension
is here for the rest of the world and
for the who team it is an
ongoing investigation for china it is a
museum piece
the world wants more than a show from
this investigation though
it wants the truth tom cheshire sky news
wuhan